Le moment de la journée que tout le monde préfère,
c'est le réveil.
Faux !
Je ne peux pas te laisser dire ça, Alan.
Tu as tout faux.
Le réveil, c'est le moment qu'on déteste le plus.
Je sais Steven, c'était de l'ironie.
Mais bien sûr.
Tu me fais honte, Alan.
Tu ne connais rien sur rien.
Tu n'es vraiment pas digne de reprendre la société de papa.
Alors là je peux te dire que j'en connais un rayon sur le réveil, alors ne me cherche pas.
Très bien.
Le premier qui n'aura plus rien à dire de pertinent sur le réveil, ne reprendra pas la société de papa.
Défi relevé.
Tu ne me fais pas peur, Steven.
Et là ?
Tu n'es carrément plus là, donc...
Bien vu.
Je prends la main.
Je t'en prie.
Quel idiot, il n'y a qu'une seule chose à dire sur le réveil.
En prenant la main, je gagne forcément.
Il y a quelque chose que tout le monde utilise, c'est le snooze.
On est dégoûté que notre réveil sonne, alors on le repousse un petit peu.
Et encore un peu... Et encore un peu.
Et au final, on se réveille super en retard.
Bien observé.
Il est foutu.
Il y a un truc horrible avec le réveil...
Hein ?!
C'est quand on fait un rêve extraordinaire, et que soudainement le réveil sonne.
Le bad.
Game over, Alan.
Je ne comprends pas de quoi tu parles.
Tu viens de faire une croix sur la société de papa.
Tu n'as jamais été interrompu dans un rêve ?
Si, si.
Du coup, tu comprends de quoi je parle.
Oui...
Du coup, c'est à toi.
Merde !
Oui...
Je t'écoute.
Euh le matin...
Quand on se réveille...
On a une haleine de phoque.
Ça veut dire quoi ?
Que les phoques eux, quand ils se réveillent... ils ont...
Une haleine de nous.
Bonne question, tiens.
J'ai eu très, très chaud. Mais là, il est cuit.
Il y a un truc embêtant avec le réveil.
Non c'est impossible, il n'y a plus rien à dire !
C'est quand on l'entend pas,
qu'on se réveille très en retard, qu'on se prépare en deux minutes...
Non !
Et qu'on arrive au travail avec la marque du drap sur la joue et des crottes aux coins des yeux.
La honte.
Ce n'est pas du tout pertinent, Alan.
Tu penses que cette expérience est universelle mais elle ne l'est pas.
C'est vrai, Steven ?
Personne n'a jamais eu de crottes aux coins des yeux.
Il n'y a qu'à toi, à qui c'est arrivé.
J'étais persuadé que ça arrivait à tout le monde.
La partie est terminée, Alan.
Ce n'est pas la vérité !
Monsieur Dominguez !
Oui.
En tant que mécanicien de la famille, je me dois de rétablir la vérité.
Steven n'a jamais eu de caca d'oeil, certes.
Mais à part lui, tout le monde a des cacas d'oeil.
Le fait est que la formation de caca d'oeil se fait pendant que tu dors, la nuit.
Or, Steven...
Dors les yeux ouverts !
Non il ment !
Comment crois-tu qu'il gagne le concours de nuit blanche chaque année ?
C'est vrai, Steven ?
Tu triches ?
Steven ?
Steven !
Oui, hein, quoi ?
Je dormais pas.
La dernière fois que j'ai dormi, c'était... y a deux jours...
Qui de Alan ou de Steven reprendra l'entreprise familiale ?
Je vous pose une question.
Ce... c'était une question en fait...
Je vous demande qui de Alan ou de Steven va reprendre l'entreprise familiale ?
Personne sait ?